authorities in south africa say that
more than 70 people have been killed in
some of the worst violence the country
has seen in years
stores and warehouses across the country
have been looted
and more than a thousand people have
been arrested the unrest erupted last
week after former president jacob zuma
began serving a prison sentence for
contempt of court
this warehouse in durban was ransacked
by hundreds of people
the shelves emptied the goods carried
out in bulk
it is only one of dozens of malls
supermarkets and small
shops that were targeted by looters
like this party supplies shop in soweto
it's over it's over i've got overheads
i've got i owe banks money
how am i going to pay this month with
what
in some instances armed local residents
went after the looters
themselves
the government sent soldiers to the most
affected areas as
police struggled to control the unrest
the current situation on the ground is
under strong surveillance
and we will ensure that it does not
deter it
any further we cannot allow anyone
to make a mockery of our democratic
state
the protest started last week after
former south african president jacob
zuma began serving a 15-month jail term
he was sentenced for contempt of court
after refusing to appear at a corruption
inquiry
the outrage of zuma's supporters was
compounded by anger
over persisting inequality and poverty
in the country
and for more let's cross over to dw
correspondent christine mundo who's
standing by in cape town christine what
is the current situation in the country
right now
sarah the looting uh continues overnight
more buildings
were set alight we know that the number
of people arrested
is well over 1 000 and we are receiving
warnings now of
looming food shortages because of the
disruptions
in guatemala natal and halting these are
key provinces
when it comes to the supply of goods
into the country
in many sites in these provinces vaccine
rollout has been affected
that is going to obviously have an
impact on what already was
a slow rollout of the vaccine here in
south africa there is also concern about
racial tensions flaring up now because
of the
lack of visibility when it comes to law
enforcement you now have
armed citizens defending their property
and in many cases it is fueling some
racial tensions people are also worried
here about the outbreak
of xenophobic violence um because all
sorts of criminality have now emerged
from uh this violence and looting sarah
okay so so we're seeing criminality but
i mean
you know by and large christine um who
are these people that we're seeing
for example looting
sarah the people you'll see looting are
underprivileged south africans for the
most part these are people who live in
informal settlements
who have been pushed further into
poverty because of the pandemic and the
restrictions that have come
with it and so what you're hearing from
the
the officials in this country is that
these people their poverty is being
exploited in fact those were the words
of a senior
ruling party official that the poverty
of people was being exploited
but what authorities are now
investigating is that these crowds these
mobs are being stoked and prompted
by a more sinister third force because
among the looters among the people going
in
and stealing basic items like food and
clothing
you have people lighting things up and
setting things on fire
who seem to want to be making
destruction
and so these people are being
investigated because it is believed
or at least they have reports have
emerged that there are some intelligence
officials
that are believed to be linked to the
former president jacob zuma who may be
behind
the stoking and mobilization of the
crowds that you are seeing but the
pictures you see these are poor south
africans
desperate and hungry who have been
pushed into further into poverty in this
pandemic
okay so i mean you know overall it it is
a desperate situation for for many there
the military has been sent out we
understand to assist
why is it proving so difficult to bring
things back under control
well law enforcement was stretched from
the very beginning there was limited
police
presence uh the deployment of the
military is controversial in itself
sarah because
it is uh essentially due to the lack and
the failure of law enforcement but what
the
the government in south africa the anc
government under cyril ramaphosa does
not want is a scenario where you have
south africans
dying at the hands of law enforcement
they do they have
as we understand it from the police
minister police have been asked to act
with maximum restraint and this is why
in a lot of the footage you will see
police officers standing helpless
watching as the crowd continues to loot
and ransack
um because the narrative of course of of
uh
this anc government firing on black
south africans in a country with the
sensitivity of the history
that we have here is the last thing that
this government wants to see and of
course that military deployment in
itself has been very very limited only
a few thousand soldiers i think 2 000
have been deployed
it is not enough to quell the the amount
of unrest that we have at the moment
christine mundo uh walking us through
what is certainly um you know a complex
and a sensitive situation there
we thank you so much for your insight
from cape town
so why did it take police so long to
react despite the warnings of unrest
well we asked professor karen runciman
director of the center of social change
at the university of johannesburg
i think it's still a very complex and
unfolding story
um there are some allegations that some
sections of the state security forces
who may be
aligned to the zuma faction may have in
some ways
surreptitiously supported what what is
happening again these are all
uh things that are coming to light as as
events unfold so it's very hard to
verify
these claims and but i think we are
certainly in a very very difficult
situation
given the scale of what we are seeing
and there are concerns
about uh the response of police and now
the deployment of army and
in south africa um neither of which have
a particularly good track record in
dealing with these things
a way that does not escalate violence